pendant l'hiver.Explication de -
PhilippeHughes.
- L'hiver cogne à nos portes.
s'apprêtent à grimper.
Mais elles seront moinssalées pe
Jean-Michel, règlent leur
consommation d'électricité
HEL LEFEBVRE,
client d'Hilo
- J'ai cthermostats
intelligents Hilo.
- Ces thermostats, développés
par une filiale d'
des pointes de consommation.
En réduisant le chauffage,
il reçoit des remboursements
en argent.
- On va penser à réduire
avec Videotron, avec Bell,
mais Hydro Québec aussi
c'est possible. Si je me
rappelle bien, j'en ai 11.es ths
Hilo varie de 200 à quelque
nécessite un contrat
de trois ans. Les clients d'Hilo
ont reçu en moyenne des crédits
sans compter les économies
de 10 à 15 % sur
annuelle pour réduction globale
de leur consommation.
à partià partià partià partià p.
- Jean-Michel estime avoir
déjà économisé 1000 $ depuis
l'installation, il y a deux ans.
- C'est là qu'on se rend c
consomme vraiment plus que
nécessaire ici, pare ici, pare e
l'électricité est moins chère.
- Parmi les conditions,
des plinthes ou des convecteurs
- C'est un système radiant,
à l'eau, dans les planchers.
- Gilles s'est plutôt tourné
la facturation dynamique,
xible.
GILLES GUEVENEUX
- Chauffage, avec chauffe-chaufi
fait circuler l'eau dans
les planchers.
- Passionné de domotique,
de systèmes centralisés pour
contrôler sa consommation.
- Tout ce que j'ai à faire,
- Hydro-Québec l'avise lorsque
des prixiels entrent
en vigueur. Les économies de
l'hiver dernier l'ont convain vi
de 363 $, qui est le crédit
hivernal. Ça a coupé ma facture
en deux.
- En moyenne, la facturation
dynamique a procuré des gains
plus modestes aux clients,
Pour la première fois cet hiver,
Québécois peuvent
y souscrire. De 160 000 foyers
l'an dercompte maintenant près
de 180 000 adhérants.
- Au début, je n'étais pas
certain, mais là c'est simple :
carrément le chauffage.
Je l'allume avant, je vais
monter d'un ou deux degrés.
- Au-delà des économies,
d'Hydro-Québec consiste à
déplacermation hors
des heures de pointe, notamment
lors des grands frBOUCHARD, pore
d'Hydro-Québec
de de pointe,
c'est là où notre réseau est
le plus sollicité. Donc l'idée,
c'est av
la pression sur le réseau
pendant une centais.s.s.s.s.s.s.
- Avec ces nouvelles modalités,
la société d'État croit pouvoir
réduire i 2030,
l'équivalent du barragela Romai.
- Pour fces pointes de
consommation-là, on doitsurdime,
on doit investir, on doit
parfois importer de
les périodes de pointes.
Ça se fait a un coût, bien
qui est moins verte que
la nôtr
- Qui gagne avec ces programmes
Hilo et tarificati
analyste du secteur énergétique
- Les ménages qui
la capacité financière,
technique de participer.
pas pour tout le monde.
À commencer par les locataires,
qui n'ont pas le pouvoir
de modifier ou d'isoler
leur logement.
- Il y a toujours près de
40 % de .
Alors ceux-là, ne sont pas
propriétaires de leursni des po,
ni des murs. Ils ont peu,
sinon pas, de possibilités
de participer au programme
d'efficacité énerg
- Pour c
aux récompenses, l'amélioration
du rendement devient une sorte
- Hydro-Québec l'offre.outoutout
la tarification dynamique,e j'a,
tu ne peux pas perdre.
- Au final, quand on voit
c'est encore plus intéressant.
- Des moyens d'opt
le réseau électrique québécois
confronté à une demande
Ici Jea Ici Jea Ici Jea Ici Je,
Radio-Canada, Laval.